let's talk about crypto i do want to get
to techcrunch in a bit but how did you
since we're on the crypto topic how did
you get into crypto
well i being in silicon valley you're
kind of crypto adjacent anyway
um you know we're obviously we're hyper
aware of bitcoin
even 10 years ago um
and eth when it first came out and was
raising money
um and we made we being my partner and i
my venture fund made some bets
in crypto um and
those bets are starting to you know
become liquid now but those were not
tokens those were
those were just equity you know equity
and things like coinbase although i
didn't invest in coinbase i didn't have
the opportunity to
um i did buy bitcoin and i think 2013
was the first time i bought it and i
think that was
when it was coinbase and uh
you know so i've held bitcoin since then
um and i bought eth very early
but again i wasn't in the crypto i was
still looking for the next ubers and
those kinds of companies that we
invested in
in 2017 though a lot of people got into
crypto in 2017.
um during the ico boom i started to take
a much harder look at crypto
and that's when i decided after doing a
couple of deals that i'd like to do it
full-time
okay and so at that point that also is
yxrp at that point i started thinking
about raising a fund
and i just knew the xrp people very well
because they're based in san francisco
and i'd known them
for a while and so i approached them
about
helping me raise that fund and that's
sort of how it all started
and um
ripple didn't actually become an lp in
the fund but
they introduced me to people that did
become lps in the fund so i owe a lot to
them
for helping me get this fund off the
ground and that's sort of how it all
started
but why specifically xrp though as
opposed to
any other sort of asset i knew i knew
people who had large amounts of capital
in
xrp and they became my initial lps
now what's interesting is at first i
wasn't going to call it
harrington xrp capital i was just going
to call it something you know my last my
venture phone was named crunchbond like
i was going to call it something
um and actually the ripple people who
aren't directly involved
actually weren't like super excited
about me calling xrp because
you know it's just unclear if i was
going to be associated with them
you know legally because of that name
but i kind of pushed because i wanted it
to be called xrp capital and so they
said okay it's fine it's actually not a
trademark go ahead and do it
and um and so it you know that that's
how that happened
and since then our lps are not
necessarily xrp holders but that's a
legacy
issue that has stayed with us and we
remain extremely loyal to the xrp
community and ripple as a company
so xrp is such a hot topic um
all the time um and i saw one of your
interviews i think you did with pump and
you were sort of talking about like the
tribalism and things like that so
tell me about the tribalism that you
felt you know
particularly just having xrp in the name
yeah it it surprised me so when i
entered crypto
again i was adjacent to crypto in tech i
understood a little bit about what
crypto was happening the tech side more
so
what i wasn't ready for was the
tribalism and
i i mean i kind of ran face first
into a wall when i announced the fund um
on stage at coindesk and i think
november or late november 2017
and suddenly there were people who loved
me who i didn't know
because i was doing an xrp denominated
fund
and there are people who truly hated me
and wanted me truly dead because i was
doing an xrp denominated fund
and i'd never seen that before like i'd
see in tech i'd seen people like apple
versus
windows type stuff before but never that
kind of tribalism
and it's taken me a few years to figure
it out because it's not very logical
like
it doesn't make a lot of sense to hate
xrp
because it's structured differently than
bitcoin or e
until you really get into the
philosophies involved in
bitcoin and ethan and everything else
and so everybody in crypto hates each
other but everyone in crypto
also agrees they hate xrp and so that
that has been like the one sort of
common theme
uh that brings everyone together is we
all hate xrp
i think that's ridiculous uh and i've
said why a million times
but it was surprising and it continues
to some extent
and it's annoying and it's sort of a
friction um
and that is what it is so yeah i think
um i
i tweeted out um maybe back in like
september last year
i wrote you know imagine hating somebody
because they prefer a different coin to
you
and um adam back who's well known to be
um
you know potentially satoshi uh-huh you
know obviously somebody very much in the
bitcoin um faction um he sort of said
imagine supporting a ponzi scheme um but
not just
about exit that wasn't just directed at
xlp as directed at directed at um
eos as directed at um i uh
pretty much all of them and i can
remember the founders sort of came
running in sort of saying wow i've lost
a lot of respect for you
for calling you know me a ponzi scheme
yeah i mean yeah this every day that's
twitter that's crypto twitter and i
think it drives a lot of people away
they don't want to get burned right so
they don't want to touch the
hot fire and and that's too bad uh
because it would be nice if we could
have
some philosophical differences but still
agree on some core set of principles but
we aren't there yet
um and i don't know what do you think
those philosophical differences are
the differences or what are the things
that could bring us together
no like those philosophical differences
do you because i sort of think it's
there's like a libertarian undertone
which sort of differentiates the two and
what do you think
differentiates the technology yeah
why do people hate different coins is
that what you're asking no no between
bitcoin
and xrp i sort of feel like they're the
antithesis of each other
oh i think bitcoin and dollars are the
antithesis of each other i think that
um i mean you have bitcoin going this
way dollar's going this way i think
you know bitcoin and xrp is more like
this in terms of the angle
um but look i mean xrp is a ledger based
currency
and it is just the way that consensus
is reached is much different than
bitcoin
and because of that difference people
feel that xrp
is more centralized and because of that
they feel the xrp is sensorable
mutable etc whether it's true or not
becomes irrelevant because this becomes
a religious war and facts become
irrelevant
uh i love bitcoin i have said and
believe that bitcoin is the alpha and
the omega
it is you know it is the sun and the
moon and my it is the most perfect
money ever invented or or even thought
of
um i also think that eath is a very
important currency and
and i believe the world computer
narrative and i think that it is
exceptionally interesting and important
plays a role of bitcoin cannot and
should not play and i think xrp does the
same as do other coins and so
i have no fundamental uh desire for xrp
to die of fiery death
uh simply because it is in some
instances less decentralized
than bitcoin for the same reason i don't
want eth to die um
because it is a totally different
currency than bitcoin and say has more
inflation
yeah i understand so essentially they
all you know have
value in different ways um
but in terms of what happened with the
sec i want to get your thoughts on that
because
that for some came out of the blue for
uh brad garlinghouse apparently
it didn't quite come out the blue um so
what are your thoughts on that um
do you think it's a security and also
like how would you define a security for
those that don't know
this is xrp obviously yeah yeah you just
asked a lot i
okay so
let's start with defining a security
let's start with defining a security if
you can
yeah okay well so i hate this question
and i'll tell you why like i like
answering it but i hate the question so
i actually was a securities lawyer
before i became an entrepreneur that was
back a ways but i wrote a book about
initial public offerings
i can't i knew i know securities law and
whether or not something is a security
even asking that question just plays
into the hands of the sec they want
everybody
using their definitions to decide what
isn't isn't
uh a security look we buy
cryptocurrencies with the hope of making
money when they're denominated in
dollars we do that because we don't
believe in dollars
anymore is that a security maybe i don't
know it depends because it's not it's
not just about
is it a security and then the
conversation's over it's is it a
security
and then if it is which is entirely a
legal definition
then the sec can really put the hurt on
you and so i think it's all securities
in the sense of like
we're all buying these things because
we're trying to get into assets that
will protect us
from what the dollar is doing but no are
we looking at the howie test
a hundred-year-old sort of test that is
absolutely useless in a modern world
it's ridiculous and so we also have to
look at the fact there's like seven
other federal
organizations that are that are
regulating crypto
and so is it a currency is it a
commodity how does the irs
tax it how does the doj and the fbi look
at all of this
and it's just a mess and so what is more
interesting than
is this a security how do we define a
security is
will the u.s come up with a coherent
regulatory scheme
that allows americans and people who
want to do business in america
to experiment with new business models
and new type of assets
to compete on a worldwide basis and the
answer so far is absolutely not the us
is only concerned with how to tax it and
how to shut it down
and so we need to fix those two problems
from a much higher perspective than
is this a security or not a security
does that answer the question
yes kind of um but from you know i think
it was a wonderful
answer to the question but i still well
well not exactly because you didn't
answer like
do you think it's a security because it
matters it matters because although you
said although you said you know we
should be focusing on other issues
like the fact that they're sort of
stifling innovation through all this tax
and this and that
um but you know as as you know the
founder of arlington xlp capital there
are a lot of xrp bag holders watching
now a lot of people sort of feel that
you know this could give
xrp clarity so um that matters as well
the d listing of xrp on many different
platforms matters just really about
you know for people holding xrp foreign
you don't want to talk philosophy you
want to talk like
down and dirty like what's actually
going to happen here and i don't have
the answers
i have no idea like yeah i mean
exchanges are delisting xrp
despite the massive volume of xrp trades
that were happening and a lot of fees
they're creating because they're scared
because they're scared of the u.s
government
and so you saw a nasty listing which is
you know
it's not that surprising um when it
comes to like what what's actually going
to happen which i think is what you're
yeah the future
is what i'd like to know look i'm i'm
hoping that we get some regulatory
clarity from this
but what i believe is the sec wants
ripple dead to put a feather in their
cap
um now that's pure speculation
based on nothing other than speculation
also the sec
is an entity that changes over time and
is changing right now in terms of sec
chairs and so
what the sec wants over time is largely
going to be dependent on what the
executive branch wants over time
and the executive branch just changed so
i have no idea i have no visibility into
what's going to happen in xrp at all
i believe the sec probably wants us to
go to trial and when it goes to trial
we'll see what happens um
but i don't know and do i think it's a
security from the point of view of the
sec no
but from the point of view of me it just
doesn't matter like
what's the security what isn't it
security is totally irrelevant
and it really just comes down to like
whether you only allow rich people to
trade an asset or you allow everybody to
trade an asset
and so when you look at like things like
uber i was able to invest in one of the
first rounds of uber and airbnb
and pinterest because i had wealth and
had a venture fund
everyday people who are just as smart or
smarter than me
also wanted to invest in those companies
or would have if they could have like
looked at the business plans like i did
but the government told them that
they're not worthy that they're too poor
and so they can't make good financial
decisions on their own
and so they're not allowed to invest in
that and so they don't get to make 10
000 x returns
on things like uber and pinterest and
airbnb
and other companies doordash is actually
a funny one because i said no to it but
all my friends became multi-millionaires
on doordash
so now it's the same damn thing the sec
comes in and they say we don't want
we don't think poor people their
definition of poor
are smart enough to make decisions the
rich people are and so we're going to
stop them from doing that
that's evil and so who cares what the
definition of a security is at the end
of the day
and we can debate that all day although
i'd probably tune out at some point
because i don't care
what i do care about is that we should
stop fraud and we should allow people to
make any decisions that they want to
make financially speaking
and that's it and that's the end of the
conversation from my point of view
because i'm only looking at it
philosophically okay so philosophically
speaking
um you know if this does hurt xrp do you
think this is therefore a threat to the
rest of the crypto space
that the question you just asked god
you're you're good at this the question
you just asked is um
is can anything take crypto down at this
point right that's really the question
you asked
so xrp is decided there's a security
it's decided by court that there were
there were securities sold
without an exemption or registration
under the securities act and everybody
that works or ever worked for ripple is
now imprisoned for life
or put to death why not do that what
happens then
yeah i think it's bad for crypto but i
think that crypto lives
lives on and um but i don't know what
that means for example let's say that
tomorrow the united states government
said that bitcoin is a national security
threat
across the board every regulatory agency
said we're not allowing bitcoin it's
illegal now
congress passes a law if you hold
bitcoin you're gonna be put to death
done would that kill bitcoin
no but it would suck and it would be de
facto dead anyway because you know
people would have to decide if they want
to hold this asset and be put to death
so i think the u.s government has a has
the ability to kill crypto
but i don't know i think as more and
more time goes on and more and more
government representatives own crypto
that becomes a less a smaller and
smaller likelihood
but no i don't think i don't think xrp
whether xrp lives or dies
has much effect on crypto in general
but what's right and wrong it matters a
lot
yeah i think i think it's kind of that
last bit which which kind of gets me i
think
what's right and wrong absolutely does
matter and whether you can sort of take
down something which is decentralized
um i don't think it's possible but in
terms of um
heavy regulation taxing every single
move that you make
i think that's sort of what will make
things harder